[Music]
this morning on the dish acclaimed chef
Ignacio Matos born in Uruguay he grew up
eating local specialties but also the
fresh pastas made by his Italian
grandmother who was his first major food
influence later came other mentors
including the legendary Alice Waters
at California's Chez Panisse he
eventually moved to New York and in 2013
opened Estella named one of vana petits
best new restaurants and later to other
venues including flora bar which led
Esquire magazine to name him chef of the
Year hot stuff and Estella Matos debut
cookbook was just released
chef Ignacio Matos welcome to the dish
good morning thanks for being here thank
you for having me here tell us about
this great spread so we have a couple of
different things so we have some
scallops if that's how the table with
which serve it with some peas and some
collard greens we have some steak served
with some delicious sauce that is funky
Italian cow's milk cheese funky Italian
right some Brussels sprouts with it and
then we have a salad of persimmons
kohlrabi pine nuts and some celery
leaves
and for dessert we're doing chocolate
even black sesame ganache okay with some
whipped cream and cocoa nibs it's like a
pretty decadent sauce and we like and
what is that bigger than thing it's a
celery celery Negroni a celery Negroni
yeah some changed color was so nice I've
sort of drinking this in the break like
I was just so drawn to it yes yeah I'm
gonna take you to a cookbook because
this is just out and I thought it was
fascinating reading about it but you
said the hardest part of doing it was
just sort of leaving the recipes alone
why was that so difficult to just put
those words down and leave it alone the
restaurant you always have that chance
of like okay I get kind of access and
change your mind and following date you
are doing little tweaks on the dish and
just it's just a different way of
14 you know like it's usually we don't
we have another chance and just like
being having to give it away and put it
out to the world and saying like that's
it I can't add a tweak here and a little
no and I try and and I get into trouble
a couple times
oh yeah I kind of learned the hard way
but yeah it's done
you got your Italian influence from your
grandmother yep that's the one
so yeah we would make pastas every week
two three times a week and like help and
you know awesome you know it's Mac for
normal you know but yeah like she's been
like the biggest influence probably on
on the way you know like that stuff she
expressed love and care and attention
for everyone you know it's all in what
was the first job in the food industry
then for you when you sort of left your
grandmother in that regard so I started
doing some catering with like a couple
old ladies in that we work overnight and
sooner next lady
soon after that I start working with a
contingent chef called Frances maman yes
we've heard of him yeah so I work for
Frances for a long time and you know
also our big influence on what the way I
had any influence you I think it's okay
like focusing on the ingredient you know
as you see the food and you can see it
on the cookbook it's it's very
ingredient ribbon so the idea is to
highlight these ingredients and focus it
on integrity and the qualities of this
ingredient without doing a lot but
elevating to a point that you are like
like wow I never imagined that brussel
sprout like that yeah or perhaps celery
you know that it's one of those
ingredients that's like who want to eat
celery anyway right so when you opened a
stella you know this is like your
trademark here you've actually said that
the ambience oh gosh that seems like
blasphemy the audience is more important
necessarily sometimes than the food I
think all elements they need to be taken
into consideration
you know like a food if you know if you
go to a restaurant that's what you do
you're supposed to provide that really
good leadership right but aside from
that it's all this sentiment is the
person that greet you at the door if I
have people pick up the phone it's the
the music the lighting which experience
this yes how did you feel about the how
did you feel about the reaction you got
when you open the restaurant it's funny
because I was talking to the landlord
and he was like you told me you were
going to do a wine bar and now you have
this fancy restaurant like well-known
like what happened you know wishes I
think like this all these tiny little
things they were aligned tweaks and them
and people just responding in a very
incredible way all the restaurants are
focused on the neighborhood in
neighborhood in the community so if we
for me it's very important to cater to
that I think in in New York particularly
we you know we appreciate this spot that
you know that you know then they
recognize you and say hey good to see
you welcome back and you know that's the
intimacy of it where everybody knows
your name well we know your name here
certainly and as you add it to the dish
if you could have a meal with anyone
past or present who would it be
that's a good question let's take you
through church Keith Richards fantastic
good enjoy that one very much chef
Ignacio Michael thank you so much thank
you for having me
and for more on chef Matos and the dish
you can head to our website at CBS this
morning calm